Und wenn es noch mal mehr als 50 oder 100 Jahr von jetzt gibt, dann müssen die Kineskope von einer Woche von allen drei Netzwerken gebeten werden. Sie finden dort, in schwarz und in weiß und in Farbe, Ebenen von Vergnügen, Eskapismus und Insulation von den Realitäten des Weltes, in der wir leben. Wir haben eine Stärkung der Allergie zu unbekannten oder beinahe unvergesslichen Informationen. Unsere massive Medien reflektieren das. Aber unless wir unsere Fatsurplüsse ausmachen und erkennen, dass die Television in der Main um uns zu beinhalten, zu beinhalten, zu beinhalten, zu beinhalten und uns zu beinhalten, dann sieht die Television in denjenigen, die es finanzieren, die es schauen und die es arbeiten.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 72. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und wir schreiben immer noch den 23. Januar 2008 und immer noch heißt, ich befinde mich auch immer noch in Wien und immer noch im MetaLab und schare interessante Gesprächspartner um mich, wie ich sie kriegen und greifen kann. Was einem im möglichen im MetaLab auch nicht sehr schwerfällt, weil hier ist doch eine extreme Technik und Know-how-Dichte zu spüren. Und so bin ich auch auf die Idee gekommen, ein weiteres Thema, was ich schon lange auf der Liste habe, mal anzugehen und zwar moderne Entwicklung von Web-Anwendungen. Wir befinden uns ja im 2.0-Zeitalter von allem Möglichen. Den Begriff kann bestimmt schon kein Mensch mehr so richtig hören. Alle rollen mit den Augen, aber so richtig wissen, was dahinter steht, vor allem technisch, das überblicken dann auch nur noch die wenigsten. Jetzt habe ich hier nochmal zwei tolle Gäste, und zwar den Esad Hajdarevic, habe ich es richtig hinbekommen, und Christopher Clay, hallo. Schön, dass ihr die Zeit gefunden habt, dabei zu sein. Ich habe euch ein bisschen rausgepickt, weil ihr so ein knuffiges Projekt gestartet habt, vor einem Jahr oder so, ungefähr, haut das hin? Etwas weniger als ein Jahr, also in 2007, und dieses Projekt heißt Soup, Suppe, die Web-Suppe. Was ist denn das? Was ist denn Soup? Könnt ihr das mal umreißen?
Okay, also Soup ist ein Tumblelogging-System. Und was ist ein Tumblelog?
Ein Tumblelog.
Genau, Tumble wie Vorbeifahren. Tumblelogging ist eine neue, multimediale, minimale Art des Bloggens. Es ist gleichzeitig eine sehr moderne Art zu bloggen. Irgendwo zwischen einem klassischen Blog und so etwas wie Twitter. Und auch eine Rückkehr zu eigentlich den Ursprüngen von Bloggen. Also ursprünglich, wenn man sich anschaut, Blogs wie Scripting News von Dave Weiner, eins der ersten, waren das hauptsächlich Linksammlungen. Also es waren nicht so Content-Management-mäßig Beiträge mit Titeln und an Texten, wo Bilder drin sind, sondern es waren so...
Man kann ja sogar noch weiter zurückgehen zu Marc Andresen und so. Das Webblog war ja eigentlich nichts anderes als das, was man heute so als History im Browser kennt, sprich die URLs, wo man durchgesurft ist und wo man sich Buchmarks gemacht hat. Also schon ein bisschen weniger als die History. Die Buchmark-Liste, das Webblog.
Genau, und mit der Zeit hat sich das dann halt immer mehr in eine Art kleines Online-Magazin oder so entwickelt, wo du Artikel verfasst und wo du echt schon fast ein kleines Content-Management-System hast, wo du lange Texte schreiben kannst und Titel und dann Bilder platzieren in diesen Texten und so weiter. Im Gegensatz dazu ist ein Tumblelog minimal. Also es besteht aus Mikrokontent, aus ganz kleinen Einträgen. Das ist vielleicht ein Foto oder ein Zitat oder ein kurzer Text oder ein Video. Also es hat diese Multimedialität, die auch ein klassisches Blog normalerweise nicht hat. Das ist dafür gemacht, dass du Text verfasst. Und da kannst du halt vielleicht zufällig auch ein Bild einbetten oder ein YouTube-Video oder was auch immer.
Ist das jetzt ein Begriff, den ihr euch ausgedacht habt?
Nein, das ist vor zwei Jahren oder so zum ersten Mal aufgekommen. Das erste Tumblelog war nach Haier von Christian Neukirchen, den wir auch mal im MetaLab später kennengelernt haben. Und ganz bekannt auch Projectionist war ein Tumblelog von einer Gruppe oder ist ein Tumblelog von einer Gruppe an Ruby-Leuten. Die diese neue Art ausprobiert haben.
Genau, sie haben sozusagen diese Bewegung gestartet. Und irgendwann gab es den ersten gehosteten Tumblerservice namens tumbler.com. Sie haben als erstes sozusagen angeboten, dass man diese Form sign up und so einen Tumblelog haben kann.
Ich weiß nicht, nochmal ganz kurz die Merkmale. Was unterscheidet einen Blog von einem Tumblelog? Ein Tumblelog hat mehr Einträge und häufigerer Einträge, dafür kürzere Einträge. Es ist höhere Frequenz und dafür kleinere Länge der Beiträge. Mehrmals täglich veröffentlicht man dort etwas. Es ist multimedial, es besteht nicht nur aus Text, sondern ein Zitat oder ein Foto sind genauso wichtig und prominent. Was Tumblelogs ausmacht, ist zu einem sehr großen Grad das Informationsdesign. Ich habe Informationsdesign studiert, deswegen mache ich diesen Begriff so gern. Wie das Interface darauf ausgelegt ist, auf diese Art von Content im Vergleich zum Interface eines Blogs, und wie der Inhalt präsentiert wird im Vergleich zu den Templates, die ein Blog hat, ist ganz, ganz wichtig. Dass die Schrift groß ist, die Spalten schmal sind, dass es funktioniert, auch wenn ich nur ein kleines Zitat poste oder ein Foto in einem WordPress-Blog oder so, würde das ganz mager ausschauen. Die Art, wie das angelegt ist und wie das dargestellt wird, beeinflusst sehr stark den Inhalt. Und wir glauben, dass da Weblogs und Blogsysteme in die falsche Richtung gegangen sind. Und durch diese Ausrichtung auf längere Artikel Erwartungshaltungen erzeugen und Anforderungen, die sich nicht decken mit dem, was die Großteil der Menschheit so publizieren will. Es ist lustiger und leichter, so kleine Beobachtungen aus dem Alltag und Sachen, die man gefunden hat und lustig findet, zu veröffentlichen, als jetzt Artikel zu schreiben. Also nichts gegen Weblogs, die sind super.
Ich denke, da hat sich dann auf Basis der Technologie unterschiedliche Publikationsmethoden entwickelt. Du hast es ja schon eingeleitet, am Anfang war der Link. Der Link stand komplett für sich selbst und sonst gab es da halt gar nichts. Dann hat sich das so weiterentwickelt, dass man den Link kommentiert, auch wenn der Link noch im Vordergrund stand. Es gibt auch heute noch einige wenige populäre Blogs, die ich auch lese, die auch noch dieses klassische Weblog-Prinzip, wo immer so ein Satz noch dazu steht. Im Vordergrund steht der Link, auch wenn man das im RSS-Feed automatisch abonniert hat, und man klickt sozusagen den angebotenen Link, man landet auf der externen Seite. Das heißt, jeder Eintrag bezieht sich immer auf das Web und nicht so sehr auf das Blog selbst. Und das ist ja dann das, dass man die Weblog-Software genommen hat als eigene Publishing-Plattform, dass nicht mehr so sehr der Link nach draußen, sondern der eigene Beitrag im Mittelpunkt steht. Das ist mehr so eine Artikel-Maschine geworden.
Und wenn man sich heute anschaut, was die größten Weblogs sind, sind das eigentlich ausnahmslos, welche, die komplett kommerziell sind, hinter den Redaktionsteams stehen. Also ich weiß nicht, Engaged und TechCrunch und Boing Boing und keine Ahnung. Also das sind nicht mehr persönliche Ansichten auf das Internet im Endeffekt. Das ist nicht mein eigener Remix von was ich cool finde im Internet, sondern das ist ein Unternehmen, die machen damit Geld. Man muss sich nur anschauen, diese ganzen Artikel, wie verdiene ich mit meinem Blog Geld? Was für Inhalte soll ich am besten? Wie komme ich auf Dig? Also Tumblelogs sind irgendwie das ehrlichere, persönlichere, direktere Medium.
Also bei Boing Boing würde ich hier nicht ganz so zustimmen, weil ich finde sowohl Boing Boing ja doch einerseits nicht so kommerziell ausgerichtet ist, aber vor allem auch immer noch sehr einig seinem Titel gerecht wird. So Director of Wonderfuls, der sich immer noch sehr aufs Web bezieht.
Stimmt und es linkt immer nach außen. Aber was für persönliche Weblogs gibt's? Ich weiß nicht, Jason Kodke vielleicht oder so. Aber die von einer Person verfasst werden und nicht mit kommensärem Hintergrund, die sehr bekannt sind. Vor 1998 waren das fast alle. Heute sind das sehr wenige. Also nicht wenige, aber nicht die großen.
Hängt natürlich immer ganz davon ab, in welche Domänen man da blickt. Aber wie auch immer, euer Fokus ist sozusagen mehr so dieses Zitieren des Webs. Und das ist ja eigentlich auch so das, was man so sieht. Du hast ja schon aufgezählt. Ihr habt ja es im Prinzip auf fünf Typen zusammengeschrieben.
Ja, aber wir haben vor in der Zukunft sozusagen dieses Angebot zu erweitern. Also zum Beispiel ein Content-Type Review oder ein Event, dass man ein Event posten kann.
Okay, aber bisher habt ihr, damit habt ihr auf jeden Fall erst mal gestartet. Was ist es? Also das ist schon erwähnt. Quoting, also dass man Leute zitiert.
Dann gibt es Text, Zitat, Bild, Video und Link.
Also Link ist sozusagen der Ur, die Ursuppe. Und dann kommen die anderen Sachen dazu. Ich finde das eine sehr interessante Sache. Vor allem dieses Zitieren. Das ist durchaus so ein Meme, was ja auch irgendwie aufgekommen ist in Blogs, dass man manchmal eben auch einfach zitiert. Aber mit Text bietet dir sozusagen auch die Möglichkeit, einfach selber zu schreiben. Also es fällt ja nicht weg.
Wobei das auch...
Ich wollte sagen, nur fürs Zitieren, zum Beispiel wir verwenden das selbst, feedback.sub.io ist zum Beispiel, was wir im Internet finden, was die Leute über uns sagen. Und das funktioniert ziemlich gut, wenn man das anschaut, das für ein Stream, von was Leute gesagt haben.
Was auch noch ganz wichtig ist, dass man in sein Tumblelog, oder vor allem bei Sub, auf drei Arten Inhalte reinbringen kann. Also entweder man verhasst sie lokal mit diesen Content-Typen, die wir gerade besprochen haben, oder man importiert einen Feed, das kann man auch machen. Also das ist im Endeffekt eine Hilfe, um mir Arbeit abzunehmen. Wenn ich bereits Fotos mache und auf Flickr hoch lade, weil ich die Funktionen bei Flickr gerne mag, dann soll ich die nicht noch mal separat in meinem Blog posten müssen, in meinem Tumblelog, sondern kann ich einfach sagen, bei Flickr heiße ich sowieso, und immer wenn dort was Neues kommt, schiebt das doch da auch ein. Also so gesehen, ist es auch so eine Mischung aus allem, was ich bei den verschiedenen Services mache. Wobei es halt nicht gedacht ist als Aggregator, sondern eben als Hilfe, damit ich nicht Arbeit duplizieren muss. Und die dritte Art ist das Bookmarklet, die ist auch ganz wichtig, gerade für diesen Link-Aspekt. Man bekommt den Bookmarklet, vielleicht kennen das die Leute von Delicious oder so, mit dem man halt ganz einfach, wenn man zum Beispiel auf YouTube ist und ein Video eben bei sich posten will, kann man unseren Bookmarklet anklicken und der erkennt dann schon, dass du auf YouTube bist und dass du wahrscheinlich dieses Video posten willst und dann kannst du nur mehr OK klicken, also einen Satz dazuschreiben vielleicht, OK klicken und dann verschwindet dieses Fenster wieder. Du bleibst dort, wo du warst und du kannst so im Vorbeisurfen das zitieren bei dir.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so ein Feature, was für mich, also ich habe jetzt zumindest noch auf keiner anderen Seite gefunden, es mag auch andere Seiten geben, die das auch so anbieten, aber das war für mich jetzt auch neu, dass man also einen Bookmark lädt, das ist ja im Prinzip nichts anderes als ein Bookmark, in dem sich JavaScript-Code befindet. Das heißt, wie du schon sagtest, ich bin halt irgendwo und finde dort Content, den ich gerne haben will, dann klickt man das und der Code ist so intelligent, quasi aus der aktuellen Seite diesen relevanten Content herauszufiltern und zu posten in meinem eigenen, ihr sagt, in meinem eigenen Soup. Und man ist eben immer noch da, wo man vorher ist. Das ist ganz pfiffig, finde ich.
Genau, mit diesem Bookmarklet entsteht so ein Use-Case, das multimediales Bookmarking sozusagen. Man kann nicht nur mehr einen Link bookmarken, so wie im Delish, sondern man kann auch ein Zitat oder ein Video oder ein Foto und so weiter von einer Seite in seinen Soup rein posten, bzw. bookmarken.
Die dann auch immer wieder zurück verlinkt sind.
Genau, genau, genau.
Und was man noch machen kann, eigentlich die vierte Methode, Sachen reinzukriegen, ist, ich kann auf die Soup von wem anderen gehen und von dort Sachen zitieren, kopieren, reposten nennen wir das. Also wenn ich bei meinem Freund ein Bild sehe, was ich wesentlich lustig finde, oder ein profundes Zitat, wo ich ihm zustimme oder so, gibt es einen Button Repostes und dann ist das auch schon bei mir zitiert mit Attributionen. Also es linkt wieder zurück zu ihm. Aber das ist auch ein Unterschied, dass bei, ja, dass es viel weniger Rolle spielt, wer jetzt wirklich der Urheber von diesem Ding ist. Also es ist nicht der Anspruch, dass du dort nur Sachen reinpostest, die von dir selber sind. Also eben dieses, ja, im Endeffekt das Linken nur erweitert auf Multimedia. Also ich kann auch einen ganzen Post von jemand anderem da...
Guck mal, was ich tolles gefunden habe. Auf einen anderen Soup, das heißt, und vielleicht muss man auch mal erläutern, also Soup ist nicht nur ein Stück Technik, sondern es ist vor allem eine Plattform, wo sich jeder quasi seine eigene Soup, sein eigenes Mini-Blog, oder mögt ihr den Begriff Microblogging in dem Zusammenhang im Übrigen?
Ich sehe Microblogging eher, also das wurde halt für Twitter verwendet. Und da gibt es schon auch große Unterschiede. Ich finde, Twitter geht noch viel mehr in Richtung Instant-Messaging. Also das ist mit dem großen Fokus auf mobile Anwendung und auf diese Zeichendimitierung auf 140 Zeichen. Und das ist halt nur Text. Also so eingeschränkt ist Soup nicht. Diese Eingeschränktheit ist, was Twitter ausmacht. Das ist auch zweifelsohne super. Aber Tumblelogging schon noch was anderes.
Okay, bleiben wir bei dem Begriff. Aber trotzdem, ihr habt sozusagen dann auch eine Community von Leuten, die eine eigene Soup sich dort geklickt haben. Das läuft dann entweder unter der domainsoup.io oder man kann sich glaube ich auch seine eigene Domain schnappen und die dort laufen lassen, oder?
Genau, wenn man es schon eigentlich hat, kann man also sein Senior-Record auf uns zeigen lassen. Und dann also das sozusagen in unser Admin-Panel kann man das eintragen und dann erkennen wir, wenn ein Request für diese Domain kommt und zeigen, also das gewählt, also das User-Soup.
Das ist halt auch richtig wichtig, zum Beispiel im Vergleich zu Twitter, dass man nicht, das ist, also wenn ich bei Soup mich anmelde, ist das nicht ein Profil, was ich bei Soup habe. So wie wenn ich bei Twitter überschreibe, dann steht darüber Twitter und ich kann nur sehr wenig anpassen und so. Und ich kann das zum Beispiel nicht auf meiner Domain laufen lassen. Aber dadurch, dass man in ein Tumblelog eben zum Beispiel rein aggregieren kann, was man anderswo macht und so, ist schon irgendwie der Anspruch da, die zentrale, also Repräsentation zu sein von dem, was du online so tust. Und deswegen liegt es sehr nahe, dass eben nicht unser Logo darüber steht und es läuft auf seiner eigenen Seite. Du kannst ziemlich viel anpassen, dass es eben nicht in dem Sinne ein Netzwerk ist, sondern ein gegrösteter, eigener Platz, den ich da habe.
Genau, also kein Social Network. Ja, ich habe es auch immer mehr verstanden, so als ein bisschen so als multimedialer Notizblock des Internets, wo man halt einfach so die Dinge gut fallen lassen kann, wo es ja ein bisschen, ja, ohne Mühe ist, eben auch so die komplexeren Mediendaten da reinzubringen. Wenn man jetzt nochmal das Beispiel mit, ich habe mein eigenes WordPress-Blog und so weiter und ich will da ein Video machen, dann muss ich dann irgendwie da den HTML-Code irgendwie kopieren und embedden und tralala. Nicht, dass das jetzt außerordentlich schwierig ist, das gelingt ja vielen Leuten, aber ihr macht das ja an der Stelle dann auch einfacher. Ja, wenn man so eine Soup haben will, geht das bei euch kostenlos, richtig?
Jaja, das ist alles kostenlos. Vielleicht sollten wir die UL nochmal explizit erwähnen. Das ist soup.io, also EO.
Genau, EO ist ganz interessant, das ist die britisch-indian-ocean-territory. Weil wir sind irgendwann auf diesen Namen Soup gekommen. Und der Name hat uns gut gefallen. Das ist so eine Mischung von was ich woanders finde und so weiter. Und tasty soup und so weiter. Wo man halt alles reinwerfen kann. Und es schmeckt trotzdem gut. Aber leider war dot.com und dot.net und so weiter. Das war alles besetzt und so weiter. Und dann haben wir so eine coole Alternative gesucht. IO war so ein bisschen Input-Output.
Also klar, das passt natürlich gut.
Genau, und wir sind ziemlich zufrieden.
Wir wollten halt auch nicht so ein Web 2.0-Klischee-Namen mit weggelassenem Vokal oder Fünfroh in der Mitte machen, nur damit wir eine.com kriegen. Dann haben wir uns gedacht, dann nehmen wir halt lieber was Exotisches.
Worauf ich mich jetzt ein bisschen mal konzentrieren wollte in diesem Podcast, sind eure Erfahrungen bei der Entwicklung dieses Systems. So populär das alles ist, ist ja doch alles noch recht neu und vor allem auch extrem in Bewegung. Da tut sich einfach eine Menge. Noch vor ein paar Jahren waren die Tools, die Werkzeuge und auch Programmiersprachen, die man heranziehen konnte, um eine wirklich stabile Web-Anwendung zu machen, dünn gesät. Zumindest bemühte sich das alles immer noch so ein bisschen aus der alten Welt, also aus der klassischen Programmierung. Ich schreibe ein Programm, was auf meinem Computer läuft. Viele haben dann halt mit Perl gearbeitet. Scriptsprachen haben da relativ früh gemacht. Aber dann gab es irgendwie so einen Bruch mit dem Vorstellen der Anwendung des Frameworks Ruby on Rails. Das verwendet ihr ja auch. Könnt ihr das so bestätigen, die Sichtweise, dass da auch so ein Schnitt passiert ist?
Das stimmt. Ich persönlich bin auch mit Perl angefangen, habe dann z.B. PHP programmiert usw. und dann habe ich irgendwann Rails entdeckt und dadurch auch Ruby on Rails usw. Ich muss zugeben, es ist ein bisschen Hype dabei. Man kann auch alle diese Sachen auch in PHP schreiben usw. Aber es ist schon ein, wie soll ich das nennen, so ein Paradigmen. Also die Paradigmen ändert sich, ja, man entwickelt, es ist, diese Idee, Convention over Configuration war zum Beispiel etwas Neues. Vorher gab es nicht, es gab zum Beispiel in der Java-Welt, gab es Frameworks, die haben schon Conventions und Configurations gehabt, aber das war sehr mühsam. Man müsste lange XML-Dateien schreiben, um irgendwie eine simple Action zu machen.
Was meinst du genau mit Conventions und Configurations?
Zum Beispiel in Ruby on Rails, wenn man einen Controller zum Beispiel Users nennt, dann ist sofort und macht zwei, drei Methoden drinnen, sind sofort diese Methoden in Slash Users, Slash Action gemapped. Das passiert sozusagen, man nennt das auch Magic und es ist viel dieses Magic dabei, aber eigentlich jedes Mal sozusagen zu mappen, Users zeigt zu dem Users-Controller und so weiter, wäre sehr mühsam. Und Rails war einer der ersten Frameworks, dass das richtig gemacht hat und das haben die Leute auch erkannt. Aber ich muss auch zugeben, dass eigentlich die Stärke von diesem Framework auch die unterliegende Sprache ist. Also man denkt, Rails ist eigentlich nur ein Framework, das in Ruby geschrieben ist. Man schreibt weiter Ruby-Code. Also es ist nicht eigene Sprache oder sowas. Und diese Sprache ist sehr mächtig und sehr dynamisch und so weiter. Zum Beispiel gab es Versuche, Rails in PHP umzuschreiben. Dann gab es diesen Kick-PHP und Grails später und so weiter. Aber meiner Meinung nach habe ich das auch ein bisschen damit gespielt, dass es nicht funktioniert, weil einfach diese Sprache nicht vorhanden ist.
Was schätze du denn so an Ruby?
Was ich an Ruby schätze, ist, dass das objektorientierte im Ruby sozusagen vollständig ist, nicht wie in Python. Also in Python gibt es primitive Typen, die dann nicht Objekte sind, sondern ich muss irgendwelche Funktionen abrufen auf diesen Typen und dann liefen sie Ergebnisse. In Ruby ist alles ein Objekt. Sogar True und False sind auch Objekte, die zu True-Class und False-Class gehören. Das kombiniert mit einer zweiten Eigenschaft, dass jede Klasse offen ist. Ich kann zum Beispiel die String-Klasse nehmen und dort neue Methoden dazugeben. Und wenn ich sage, ich nehme eine Methode Scramble und führ das zum String und wenn ich sage, im String-Assad und dann Scramble, dann Scramble, da ist das so, aie, zum Beispiel. Also ich kann bestehende Klassen erweitern. Viele haben gesagt, das ist gefährlich, das bricht zusammen. Aber Ruby hat auch in der Philosophie, das Programmieren ist nicht dumm. Die Leute sagen auch, ohne statisches Typen geht das nicht, das bricht alles zusammen. Nein, wenn man, wir Programmierer sind nicht dumm. Wenn man auf diese Sachen achtet, dann geht das. Wie gesagt, das Objektsystem in Ruby ist sehr mächtig. Diese Offenheit ist sehr mächtig. Es unterstützt Lambda, Clojures, es unterstützt, es hat viel viel von diesem Syntax-Sugar.
Fast schon zu viel.
Stimmt, manchmal auch zu viel. Man kann eine Methode mit Klammern oder ohne Klammern abrufen.
Jetzt sollte man kurz mal erläutern, wo Ruby herkommt. Das ist ja eine Sprache, die interessanterweise von einem Japaner entwickelt wurde. Das kennen sonst gar keine populäre Poemiersprache, die man nicht aus den USA kommt. Er hat dann eine ganze Zeit lang so ein Dasein gefristet. Er hatte so ein bisschen so seine Freunde. Er wurde dann aber schon rasant weiterentwickelt. Er hat sich aber dann eigentlich erstmal, war zumindest mein Gefühl, sehr viel mehr als die nettere Variante von Pearl positioniert. Also war ganz klar in dieser Unix-Scripting-Welt drin. Man kann eigentlich genauso elegant mit Ruby Skripte schreiben, wie man es vorher mit Shell oder mit Pearl war. Bloß, dass es irgendwie, eben wie du schon gesagt hast, komplett mit einem Objektsystem daherkam und sich ja vor allem an Smalltalk orientiert hat.
Also so ein Klassiker. Der Autor von Ruby bestätigt das selbst. Der sagt, dass er von Pearl inspiriert würde und von allen Programmiersprachen, die er kannte, wie Smalltalk und so weiter, auch Python und so weiter. Und er hat einfach die besten Sachen in einer kohärenten Weise zusammengestellt in einer Programmiersprache. Das heißt, man kann, also Leute, die von Smalltalk kommen, werden vieles erkennen. Auch viele Pearl-Idiomen sind drinnen. Ich weiß nicht, Regular Expressions gehen sehr einfach.
Was ja auch eine wichtige Sache ist, wenn man sich gegen Pearl behaupten will, weil das ja natürlich immer eine große Stärke war, von Pearl gut mit Strings und Regular Expressions und so weiter umgehen zu können.
Und die Sprache, ich glaube, ist dem 93 entstanden. Aber würde in Japan für allgemeine Anwendungen und so weiter, als Scriptingsprache, also war sehr populär. Aber eigentlich der Durchbruch war mit dem Rails-Framework. Und wo ich in so einem Interview gelesen habe, hat der David Hansen, der Autor von Rails, hat damals, wollte eine Web-Applikation schreiben und suchte eine Sprache, die mächtig ist, mit String-Processing und so, die genügend Libraries hat und so weiter und hat Ruby gefunden und hat angefangen, das in Ruby zu schreiben. Eigentlich hat er angefangen, haben sie angefangen, interne, also Basecamp und so weiter, also ihre Produkte zu schreiben und daraus haben sie den Framework...
37signals ist ihre Firma oder Organisation.
Sie haben in laufer der Zeit dieses Framework aus ihren Produkten sozusagen extrahiert. Und das ist sehr wichtig, weil viele Frameworks entstehen sozusagen im Voraus. Einige Leute setzen sich zusammen oder in Programmierung und sagen, ich bräuchte das und das wäre schon cool und so weiter und dann entstehen Sachen, die man nicht braucht. Also dann bloatet Frameworks und so weiter. Und man merkt, dass Rails ein bisschen organischer so entstanden ist.
Das Rails Framework bringt ja auch noch eine ganz interessante Methodik einher, die auch bei Smalltalk ursprünglich mal erfunden wurde, dieses Model-View-Controller-Konzept für User-Interfaces, was ja bei Smalltalk das erste Mal sozusagen für GUI-Anwendungen genommen wurde. Von Apple interessanterweise mit Web-Objects das erste Mal für Web-Anwendungen übernommen wurde. Und Apple hat ja auch mit Objective-C auch einen ähnlichen Ansatz, dynamische Sprache, Model-View-Controller, dynamische Sprache, habe ich schon gesagt. Und bringt ja das zusammen auch so der Framework-Gedanke. Ich hatte jetzt hier vor zwei Ausgaben zurück. Bei Chaosradio Express haben wir uns auch ausführlich über Macintosh Software-Entwicklung unterhalten, wie das dort mit den Frameworks läuft. Das ist ja so ein ähnlicher Aspekt. Man kann halt, und das ist ja auch bei Rails der Fall, mit null Code hat man eine laufende Anwendung. Also man fängt halt an und sagt, ich hätte jetzt ganz gerne mal eine Anwendung. Und man fügt einfach genau gar nichts hinzu, außer vielleicht einen Titel zu geben. Und schon funktioniert etwas. Das heißt, das Ding bringt seine eigene Funktionalität mit. Und das war dann eben so mein Eindruck. Das hat einfach diese Web-Development extrem beschleunigt. Und dadurch, dass Model-View-Controller, Ruby und dann eben auch dieses Rails so wunderbar zusammengepasst haben, brach dann irgendwie auf Brachen auf einmal alle Dämme.
Ich muss zugeben, dass, also ich muss noch was erwähnen, was sehr wichtig ist, ist diese Model-Teil bei Ruby. Das ist Active Record, heißt das. Und das war, also Ruby, da sind alle Stärken.
Das ist der Teil in diesem Model-View-Controller, der sozusagen die Datenbasis hat.
Genau, das ist eigentlich die ORM, also Object Relational Mapping. Das heißt, dadurch arbeitet man mit der Datenbank. Und das ist einer der Teile, die am meisten die Stärke von Ruby zeigt. Weil zum Beispiel, wenn man eine Klasse macht namens User, und das ist auch dieser Convention over Configuration, man muss nicht sagen, dass diese Klasse die Tabelle Users mappt, sondern das ist per Default. Und wenn man eine andere Tabelle in dieser Klasse abbilden will, dann muss man das sagen. Aber per Default ist sie gleich wieder plural von dem Klassennamen. Das heißt, wenn ich sage Class User, Extended Active Record Base, dann ist sofort das sozusagen angehängt an die Tabelle Users. Und ich muss auch nicht die Attribute, die in dieser Tabelle vorhanden sind, definieren. Sondern sie werden dynamisch, wenn das ausgeführt wird, werden sie in die Objekte, die zurückgeliefert werden, sozusagen definiert. Oder Injected Attribute. Das heißt, ich sage einfach User Find First. Und ich kann schon auf diesem Objekt habe ich Methoden, wie wenn die Felder vorhanden sind, Punkt Name. Und ich kann sagen, Punkt Name ist jetzt Esad und dann Save und so weiter. Das heißt, dieser mühelose Arbeiten mit der Datenbank. Also im PHP-Welt ohne Framework wäre das, ich weiß nicht, eine Select-Query schreiben und dann durch den Result-Set loopen und dann extrakieren und so weiter.
Und vor allem mit zwei Sprachen arbeiten. Man hat dann für das PHP und man hat das SQL, muss es irgendwie zusammenbringen. Und das macht man bei Ruby dann an der Stelle gar nicht.
Und ich meine, es ist nicht allmächtig für etwas Komplizierteres. Also es gehen ziemlich komplexer Queries, aber irgendwann muss man doch sagen, find by SQL, und dann also manuell das Query schreiben und so weiter. Aber ich finde auch, relativ gut kann man in Rails, wenn etwas nicht vorhanden ist, wie zum Beispiel, wenn etwas unmöglich ist, mit dieser Fein-Methode, also mit eingebauten Methoden zu machen, kann man wieder auf SQL zurückgreifen und so weiter.
Also man ist nicht gefangen in dem System, aber es nimmt einem überall da die Arbeit ab, wo man irgendwie nicht immer wieder von A anfangen möchte.
Weil ich habe Framework gekannt, die mir viel mehr im Weg gestanden sind. Also die haben mir 30% der Zeit geholfen, aber 70% der Zeit habe ich so way around the Framework gesucht, so ach, das geht nicht und jetzt muss ich und so weiter. Und dadurch, dass alle Klassen offen sind in Ruby, ich kann jede Methode von jeder Klasse, die vorhanden ist, überschreiben und das nennt man Monkey-Patching. Ja, ich kann sagen, ruf die Parent-Methode und dann aber nachher tu noch das oder völlig was anderes. Man kann Verhalten ändern, also vom Framework.
Das heißt, Soup ist mit Ruby on Rails entwickelt worden, so, komplett. Und das hat euch wahrscheinlich eine Menge Zeit und Stress gespart. So, dass er erst mal, das lächelt er schon. Also da ist sicherlich noch eine Menge Stress übrig geblieben. So, aber das ist das eine. Aber jetzt ist ja, wenn ich mir Soup so anschaue, das ist ja auch etwas, was mit diesem Rails-Phänomen kam. Also zweierlei, das erste, was mit Rails kam, was sie ein interessantes kulturelles Phänomen fand, auf einmal sah das alles schick aus. Also vorher hatte man es immer mit diesen pothässlichen Anwendungen zu tun. Und alles, was aus dieser Rails-Welt kam, das hatte auch einfach so einen gewissen optischen Appeal, der vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt immer das Wichtigste ist, aber das ist ja auch mal ganz nett, wenn man nicht die ganze Zeit ja rein kotzen möchte in seinen Browser. Also, dass man sich auch ordentlich behandelt fühlt.
Das hatte bestimmt auch zu tun mit dem, wo es hergekommen ist. Also von 37signals, die ja eigentlich also Usability gemacht haben, vorher, bevor sie in Web-Applikationen eingestiegen sind. Was ja witzig ist, weil einerseits Ruby on Rails kommt aus einer Usability-Firma, und andererseits zumindest den Begriff Ajax hat Adaptive Path geprägt, die auch eine Usability-Firma waren. Also es ist komisch, dass aus dieser Ecke die Zutaten von Web 2.0 gekommen sind. Vor allem bei Ajax, nicht auf technischer Seite, da haben sie ja nichts neu entwickelt, aber diesen Einfluss finde ich lustig. Das ist eben nicht aus einem universitären Umfeld oder so.
Ist das auch eine Methode, die ihr anwendet bei eurer Entwicklung? Macht ihr Tests? Macht ihr Usability-Tests?
Bis jetzt nicht, und das ist zu unserem Nachteil. Wir machen das jetzt schon ein paar Monate und werden jetzt eine deutsche Version rausbringen und wollen uns auch ein bisschen kümmern um Medienarbeit und solche Sachen mal. Dafür müssen wir auf jeden Fall Usability-Tests machen, weil wir haben da einige Schwachstellen, die wir ausbilden müssen. Das sollte man eigentlich jedem von Anfang an empfehlen. Muss ja auch nichts großes sein, aber Leute mal hinsetzen, die das noch nicht gesehen haben und ihnen über die Schulter schauen.
Jetzt hast du schon einen interessanten zweiten Teil angesprochen. Bei Ruby on Rails sind wir ja nach wie vor da klassisch auf dem Server. Das heißt, das ist die eigentliche Kernanwendung. Da lauert die Datenbank, dass es die Kernfunktionalität, die bereitgestellt wird. Aber ein Merkmal moderner Web-Anwicklung ist ja auch die, dass es sich einfacher bedient. Früher hatte man einfach so Formulare und Links und das war es dann eigentlich im Wesentlichen. Und insbesondere so die Manipulation komplexer Datenmodelle war schwierig. Einfache Dinge waren immer sehr aufwendig und klassische Probleme, somit irgendwie vorwärts, rückwärts und Cache-Problemen und so weiter. Also die auch immer eine ganze Menge Sicherheitsprobleme aufgestoßen haben. Das hast du schon gesagt. Dann gab es diese Company Adaptive Paths. Wusste gar nicht, dass die auch so einen Usability-Hintergrund haben. Haben dann den Nutzen daraus gezogen, dass ja eigentlich schon seit langer, langer Zeit JavaScript als Option in den Web-Browsern mit eingebaut war. Netzcape hat das irgendwann mal, ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie das auch erfunden haben, die Sprache. Doch, ich glaube schon. Die waren im Wesentlichen dahinter genau, haben das eingebaut. Das war dann ja lange Zeit sehr umstritten und unbeliebt. Nicht ganz zu unrecht, weil es natürlich vor allem erst mal dafür gesorgt hat, dass Seiten halt auch einfach nicht mehr so accessible waren und überhaupt eine ganze Menge Ärger und natürlich auch Sicherheitsprobleme mit sich gebracht haben. Da ist dann ein sehr langer Marsch hingelegt worden. In dem Prozess haben sich natürlich eine Menge Leute damit auch vertraut gemacht. Interessanterweise war es dann Microsoft, die das erste Mal gesagt haben, naja, da kann man ja auch wirklich mal ein paar ganz interessante Sachen mit machen. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie das bei ihnen hieß. Die hatten wieder irgendeinen obskuren Namen, Live irgendwas, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall hat dann, ich weiß nicht, ob das dieser Begriff war, der das dann ausgelöst hat, aber es gab halt irgendwann dieses AJAX. AJAX steht für?
Asynchronous JavaScript, was ist das nächste A? Ich glaube, ja.
Kannst du mal beschreiben, was dahinter steht?
Na ja, eigentlich steht dahinter, dass XML hatte die PayRequest-Objekt, was eben, wie du angesprochen hast, von Microsoft, also im IE ursprünglich, implementiert wurde und nie in einem Standard-Stand bis jetzt nicht. Also das sind zwar alle nachgezogen, aber das ist vollkommen proprietär eigentlich ursprünglich. Da geht es einfach darum, dass ich Daten in einer Seite nachladen kann und Request absetzen, ohne dass ich die gesamte Seite neu lade. Also statt dass ich einen Link anklick und dann komme ich auf eine andere URL und da steht etwas anderes, kann quasi im Hintergrund etwas ablaufen. Ich schicke ein Request und es kommt eine Antwort und ich ändere je nach Antwort irgendwas auf der Seite, ohne dass der User sich davon wegbewegt und ja, ohne dass ein Formular abgeschickt wurde, solche Sachen. Das war ganz enorm wichtig. Also das ist das, ohne das gibt es das schöne Marketing-Wort WebZenor überhaupt nicht. eigentlich dann ermöglicht hat, dass Web-Applikationen, die Interfaces von Web-Applikationen sich annähern den Interfaces von Desktop-Applikationen. Noch weiter von weg, aber das ist bequemer und schöner wird, als klassische Formular-basierte Applikationen. Bestes Beispiel ist Google Maps zum Beispiel. Also das war ja ein enormer Quantensprung, wenn man das vergleicht mit was vorher da war, ich weiß nicht MapQuest oder so, wo ich halt eine ganz kleine Karte habe und dann gibt's einen File-Button und dann klicke ich und dann warte ich mal, dann lädt die ganze Werbung rundherum neu und dann kriege ich einen neuen Kartenausschnitt. Also der Unterschied zu Google Maps, wo ich halt klicke und ziehe und die Map-Tiles laden sich nach und so weiter und ich kann rein und raus zoomen, das wäre ohne Ajax nicht möglich. Beziehungsweise Ajax, also es ist ja nicht immer, dass XML hat DDP-Request dabei verwendet, Objekte dabei verwendet und es ist ja nicht immer XML. Also das ist ja eigentlich ein falscher Name, aber Webzine-Oral ist ja auch ein falscher Name. Damit muss man sich abwenden. Es sind beides Hype- und Marketing-Begriffe, die man kritisieren kann, aber in denen ein Kern an Wahrheit und Nützlichkeit steckt auf jeden Fall. Ja, und diese neue Art der Interfaces hat das ermöglichten. Das ist auch bei Soup ein ziemlich zentraler Teil. Das wir zum Beispiel nicht wie klassische Blog-Software ein Administrationsinterface haben, wo du alle deine Inhalte nochmal in einer anderen Form siehst und dort kannst du sie bearbeiten, sondern das ist alles in Place, also direkt dort, wo die Ausgabe ist, kann ich auch wechseln in Irritiermodus und dann kann ich einfach reinklicken und die Sachen ändern und abspeichern, ohne dass sich da alles neu lädt oder so. Was einfach dazu beiträgt, dass das Hürden abbaut und direkter und leichter zu bedienen ist.
Also einerseits besseres User-Interface, andererseits hilft es auch sozusagen bei der Softwareentwicklung, könnte ich mir vorstellen, weil man weniger modellieren muss. Man hat nicht erstmal so komplett neues User-Interface und dann alles nochmal von vorne, wo man eigentlich nur noch so eine kleine Schraube hinzufügen. Finde ich das richtig?
Genau, und es ermöglicht halt Sachen wie Web-basierte Instant-Messaging-Clients und so, die vorher einfach nichts zu machen waren. Also auch rein funktionalitätsmäßig, das konnte man sonst nicht machen.
Außer mit einer Meta-Refreshung dann.
Ja, es gab so allerlei Klimmzüge, aber jetzt ist es ja irgendwie klar. Google is leading the path, würde ich sagen. Also Google Maps ist das eine Beispiel, Gmail ist definitiv ein anderes Beispiel, wo man auch sieht, was für eine, also einerseits was im User-Interface-Bereich gemacht wird, aber was auch an Funktionalität in Web-Anwendungen drinsteckt. Oder auch das iPhone ist sicherlich ein gutes Beispiel. Ich meine, Apple hat das Ding rausgebracht und gesagt, naja, ihr seid Third-Party, ihr wollt entwickeln, kein Problem, wir haben doch JavaScript.
Es ist doch ein Browser drin.
Genau, es ist doch ein Browser drin. Und man sieht, dass es möglich ist, auch Webseiten auf dieses rudimentäre Interface runterzubrechen und dem durchaus noch Funktionalität zu machen. Da wird natürlich dann mit dem SDK noch der zweite Schritt kommen. Dann wird das nochmal ganz anders sein. Aber es zeigt, es geht. Oder auch Desktop-Widgets gehen in die gleiche Richtung. Auf Mac, das Dashboard, auf anderen Plattformen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie heißt das jetzt. Bei Vista gibt es das im Prinzip auch. Gadgets, glaube ich. Auch bei KDE4 kommt das jetzt mit rein.
Ja, JavaScript ist auch keine schlechte Programmiersprache. Du hast vorher den schlechten Ruf angesprochen. Es ist wahrscheinlich die wichtigste und meistverwendete Sprache mit dem verhältnismäßig schlechtesten Ruf, die es jemals gegeben hat.
Was sind denn so die Eigenschaften von JavaScript?
Also JavaScript ist gar nicht...
Ich wollte nur erwähnen das Helmer-Framework erwähnen. Nur kurz, das ist interessant. Das ist ein Web-Framework, das ist in JavaScript. Also du hast damit gearbeitet. Server-seitiges JavaScript, wo man halt auch Server-Teil in JavaScript schreibt.
Das ist eine österreichische Erfindung, oder?
Genau, ich habe es nicht verwendet. Christopher hat in einer Firma gearbeitet, für eine Firma, die das entwickelt hat.
Das war diese Blogging-Plattform, oder?
To-day, wenn du das meinst. Also Knallgau heißt die Firma. Ja, es gibt durchaus Ansätze, auch server-seitig mit JavaScript zu arbeiten. Und das ist nicht katastrophal. Also das funktioniert. JavaScript ist gar nicht so unähnlich, als ich vorher dem Esad zugehört habe, wie er Ruby-Features aufgezählt hat. Diese Modifizierbarkeit der Objekte in runtime. Also keine Strict Typing und so. Das ist alles bei JavaScript genauso. Also Lambda, Closures, hast du alles auch.
Ja, es braucht eine funktionale, dynamische Sprache.
Genau, ein großer Unterschied ist das Objektsystem. Also es gibt nicht dieses klassische Klassensystem, was man kennt, es gibt schon Libraries, die das dann implementieren, wenn man sie unbedingt auf die Weise operieren will. Aber grundsätzlich ist Prototypal Inheritance das Modell, das in JavaScript gewählt wurde. Und das ist exotisch. Also für die meisten ist das, das ist ein Umland-Prozess mit dem umgehen zu können. Aber es gibt Leute, die die Meinung vertreten, dass das durchaus seine eigenen Vorteile hat.
Beschreib doch mal.
Ja, was aber witzig ist, finde ich, ist, dass wenn man sich anschaut, den JavaScript-Code, der da im Internet existiert, benützen 99% davon wahrscheinlich nicht einmal auch nur das geringste von Prototypal Inheritance. Und meistens sind das kleine, kurze, schnell definierte Funktionen inline, die halt, und sobald dann ein anderes JavaScript eingebettet wird, was denselben Namen verwendet in ihren Funktionen, zerbricht alles. Aber das muss nicht sein. Man kann das auch sehr schön namespacen. Man kann mit ein paar kleinen Tricks so quasi private Methoden haben und Objekte bauen. Aber Prototypal Inheritance, kannst du das schön in der Kaste erklären?
Man nimmt, also zum Beispiel in traditionellem OOP, nimmt man eine Klasse und dann hat man eine Instanz dieser Klasse. Das hat alle Methoden, die in einer Klasse definiert sind und so weiter. In dem Prototype-based OOP, also macht man das so, man hat ein Objekt.
Da gibt es sozusagen keine Klassen.
Genau, es gibt keine Klassen, sondern man hat, ich weiss nicht, wie das genau heißt, man hat so ein Originalobjekt. Und wenn man sozusagen Instanzen von diesem Objekt hat, macht man eine Kopie von diesem Objekt und arbeitet damit. Das heißt, alle Objekte sind Instanzen bereits. Also das sind, alles sind Objekte. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel mache ich ein Prototype-Objekt namens User. Und wenn ich jetzt einen echten User haben will, dann mache ich eine Kopie und fühle das mit Daten ein.
Das andere Objekt ist sozusagen dann der Prototyp.
Genau, aber zum Beispiel, wenn ich User haben will und dann will ich eine, in traditionellem Sinne, also Subklasse haben, Admin, dann mache ich einfach eine Kopie von User, füge die Funktionalität zu dem Admin und dann mache ich die Kopien von diesem Objekt Admin und da sind dann die Instanzen in traditionellem Sinne.
Spart auf jeden Fall auch Speicher. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es wisst, aber es gab ja noch eine andere, nicht sehr populäre, aber auf jeden Fall sehr viel aufmerksam erregende Plattform, die eine ähnliche Programmiersprache verwendet hat, die auch mit Prototyping gearbeitet hat. Das war der Apple Newton. Newton's Script hat auch auf Prototyping basiert. Es gibt auch, glaube ich, von Sun eine Programmiersprache, die heißt Self, die auch so ein ähnliches Konzept macht. Also es ist auch nichts, was jetzt mit JavaScript wirklich komplett neu war. Da ist ja eigentlich auch nur so ein bisschen wieder herausgekramt, was man bis dahin schon so an Softwareentwicklungskenntnissen hatten, aber dann eben für diesen neuen Anwendungsfall. Aber so der erste NetScape-Browser und so, wir wissen alle, da war nicht so viel Platz im Rahmen und so weiter. Also von daher war das auch schon so ein Zwang, der da mit reinspielt. Und auch so der Newton war ja in seiner ganzen Erscheinung dann eigentlich auch sehr vergleichbar mit so einem Browser, mit so einfachen Formularen und so weiter. Das ist immer sehr interessant zu sehen, was so seine Vergangenheit da immer noch mit sich herumschleift. Prototype ist ja auch der Name eines JavaScript-Frameworks, was immer wieder im Gespräch ist. Hast du das auch im Einsatz?
Das verwenden wir auch, das ist ja auch standardmäßig bei Ruby on Rails dabei. Was auch noch dabei ist bei Ruby on Rails normalerweise, ist Scriptaculous, das ist so eine Effect-Library im Endeffekt. Wir benutzen Prototype, aber nicht Scriptaculous. Der Grund dafür ist, dass Prototype einfach... Der Hauptgrund, warum JavaScript so einen schlechten Ruf hat, sind die Browser. Also nicht JavaScript als Sprache, sondern die Implementation in verschiedenen Browsern über die Jahre, die oft zu wünschen übrig gelassen hat. Die Sicherheitsprobleme, die bei der Integration in den Browsern auftreten. Wie zum Beispiel diese schreckliche Idee, dass JavaScript Pseudoprotokolls, dass ich eine URL basteln kann, die JavaScript enthält. Und dann überall, wo ich sonst URLs angeben kann, kann ich auch Skript auf einmal ausführen. Komplett wahnsinnige Idee.
Obwohl ihr das ja auch benutzt für Bookmarklets.
Ja, eben, und das geht es Bookmarklets nicht, aber an sich eine komplett wahnsinnige Idee. Also was sie sich da eingehandelt haben an Problemen. Das stimmt. Aber also Prototype nimmt einem irrsinnig viel, also Prototype.js, die Library, sehr verwirrend benannt, nimmt einem in Bezug auf Browser und Interoperativität und Komfort viel ab. Es kommt eben auch aus dieser Ruby- und Rails-Ecke und versucht, auch JavaScript von der Syntax her so hinzu biegen, dass es ein bisschen ähnlicher wird wie Ruby. Wie zum Beispiel, wenn ich durch einen Array durchlupen will, dass ich halt nicht mit einer Vorschleife, wie sonst in JavaScript das mache, sondern dass ich sagen kann, Array.each. Die Syntax nachher ist dann halt nicht so schön wie in Ruby, weil ich brauche dann noch fünf Klammern und das war die Funktion und eine geschwungene Kammer und dann wieder zu und dann Strichpunkt. Aber grundsätzlich versucht das, das ein bisschen anzugleichen. Und das ist alles irrsinnig bequem. Ich war am Anfang immer ein bisschen skeptisch, so Prototype hat, ich weiß nicht, 40 Kilobyte und die müssen doch immer übertragen werden. Zahlt sich das wirklich aus? Aber ja, es zahlt sich auf jeden Fall aus. Also die Geschwindigkeit, die man beim Entwickeln gewinnt, dadurch, dass man halt auch das Document Object Model, also wie die HTML-Elemente per JavaScript, wie man auf die zugreifen kann, wird durch Prototype so sehr erleichtert, dass man, wenn man das einmal gemacht hat, einfach ohne das.
Man hat keine 40 Kilobyte, jedes Bild.
Hat auch mehr, ja. Und außerdem, nach dem ersten Mal ist es eben Caching.
Genau.
Und es wird dann auch wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger gesippt übertragen. Also das ist nicht so schwer, wie es klingt.
Ja, aber was ich eigentlich irgendwann mal angefangen habe, den Satz ist, warum wir Skriptakulus nicht verwenden, ist, dass es auch sehr nett, wenn man halt schöne Effekte, wie Sachen, die also ausblenden oder sich bewegen machen will. Aber du bist halt dann dort noch viel mehr als bei Prototype selbst gebunden an diese Effekte, die die da anbieten. Und dann hast du halt diese acht Standard-Effekte und die siehst du halt jetzt an jeder Ruby on Rails-Applikation. Und wenn du wirklich was Innovatives machen willst mit dem Interface, dann kannst du halt auf lange Sicht nicht mit so einer Library arbeiten, sondern musst dir deine eigenen Sachen basteln. Also Google Maps zum Beispiel, mein Lieblingsbeispiel von modernen Web-Interfaces. Klar, die mussten sich das selber schreiben. Da gibt es keine Library, die das implementiert, wie man in einem Rahmen drag und dropen kann und so weiter. Also es ist eher nicht hilfreich, aber benutzen wir jetzt nicht.
Wir hatten das ja schon eingangs beim AJAX festgehalten. Das hat sozusagen seinen Teil zur Web 2.0 Revolution jetzt mal in großen Anführungsstrichen beigetragen. Jetzt haben wir eigentlich nur das J angeschaut. Jetzt gibt es auch noch das X, XML. Das spielt ja auch nicht gerade eine geringe Rolle in der Webentwicklung. Also einerseits natürlich als Data Storage. Es gibt bestimmt kein Softwareprojekt heutzutage, das nicht irgendwo in eine XML-Datei rumfliegen hat, weil jede Programmiersprache die Möglichkeit bietet, XML leicht zu lesen und wieder zu schreiben. Man hat halt endlich mal ein einheitliches System, in dem strukturierte Informationen gespeichert werden können und es kann sogar umlaute. Das darf man ja nicht unterschätzen. Aber vor allem spielt XML auch eine sehr große Rolle im Web, in den Protokoll. Gerade jetzt beim Blogging. Blogging ist ja eigentlich auch, ich finde Blogging jetzt nicht nur so von seinem kulturellen Phänomen interessant, sondern es ist ja auch, dass es die Web-Anwendungen und die Web-Protokolle extrem befördert hat. Also schon sehr früh, in frühen Zeiten, das ist ja auch noch auf diesen von dir schon erwähnten Dave Weiner zurückzuführen, gab es die Möglichkeit, verschiedene Sachen, also einerseits gab es diesen Ping. Das heißt, ich poste etwas in meinem Web-Blog und das Web-Blog kann einem zentralen Web-Blog-Trecker sagen, dass da jetzt was Neues ist, sodass man so ein zentrales Repository hat, das mag am Anfang noch ganz prima funktioniert haben. Bei der Masse an Blog-Posts, die heute aufschlagen, haben die Server, die sich heute trotzdem noch darum kümmern, also Technorati und solche Indizierungssysteme, doch schwer zu kämpfen. Hab ich mal mit jemandem unterhalten, der so eine Blog-Auswertungsmaschine macht. Das muss einfach absurd sein, was da aufprasselt. Trotz alledem, all diese Protokolle verwenden intern XML. Auch bei dem AJAX steckt ja im Prinzip drin, dass man eben Daten austauscht.
Wobei das ja eben bei AJAX in den selbtesten Fällen in der Praxis noch wirklich XML ist. Meistens übertragen die Leute eigentlich kleine HTML-Schnipsel, die sie dann irgendwo einfügen in die Seite. Oder wenn sie wirklich nur die Daten wollen, auf JSON. XML habe ich da selten gesehen in letzter Zeit, dass das wirklich jemand XML überträgt und dann in JavaScript passt und wieder ausbricht.
Auf JSON, das können wir nochmal kurz einbringen, das stimmt. Also JSON ist so eine neue Entwicklung. Überhaupt sieht man, viel orientiert sich jetzt an JavaScript. Also man merkt, JavaScript wird so übermächtig, also wird an so vielen Stellen genutzt, dass man eben auch möchte, dass man sozusagen nativer reden möchte, sodass eben auch dieses Einpacken der Daten in XML jetzt auch in JavaScript Syntax gemacht wird. Es folgt aber eigentlich immer demselben Konzept. Man hat halt einfach hierarchische Strukturen, Elemente und Attribute und das Ganze ist irgendwie so gepackt, dass eben klar ist, wie die Strings codiert sind. JSON ist dann eigentlich nichts anderes als Syntax-Sugar. Das heißt, man kann es hinschreiben wie JavaScript und man kommuniziert mit der Gegenseite. Bloß man schickt halt JavaScript-Code hin und her und nicht mehr XML.
Es ist also Object Literals in JavaScript. Also genau, sehr kompakte Formen, wie du eben die Datentypen, Arrays und Objects und so.
Ich meine, sonst müsste man halt XML serialisieren und deserialisieren. Das heißt, ich muss aus dem XML, das mir zurückkommt, irgendwie wieder meine Objekte oder Daten extrahieren. Hier kann man theoretisch JSON, also das JSON-Reply auch auswerten lassen und kriegt dann ein JavaScript-Objekt, obwohl das so ein bisschen security-mäßig ist.
Ja gut, aber das macht ja XML nicht obsolet. Ich meine, auch Soup ist in der Lage, seinen Inhalt per RSS via XML zu syndizieren. Und ein weiteres Format, was ja jetzt so dabei ist, die Nachfolge anzutreten, von RSS ist Atom, so ein gemeinsamer Effort der Blogging-Szene. Daran endlich mal diese RSS-Konfusion zu beenden. Sieht auch nach einem potenziellen Erfolg aus. In the long run wird noch eine Weile dauern. Aber dieses Atom-Atom ist auf jeden Fall gut nachgedacht. Also da ist wirklich mal ein bisschen Gehirnschmalz investiert worden. Man hat gemerkt, dass die Leute, die da beteiligt sind, dieses Thema dann wirklich mal tot treten wollten. Und dann keinen Bock mehr hatten, sich noch weiter mit Dave Weiner darüber zu streiten, wie die Dinge jetzt zu sein haben oder nicht. Und dabei ist ja was ganz interessantes herausgekommen. Also einerseits eben ein Nachfolgeformat für RSS, in dem einfach mal alles so stringent definiert ist, dass man dann auch mal weiß, was bedeutet.
Und wie das Datum wirklich formatiert sein soll.
Das war ja bei RSS immer noch ganz böse. Da habe ich auch immer mit zu kämpfen. Aber dann gibt es ja auch noch dieses Atom als Protokoll. Was spielt denn das für eine Rolle?
Ja, das Atom Publishing-Protokoll ist eine ganz simple restbasierte. Wir machen heute alle Buzzwords durch.
Ja, darum geht es ja hier auch. Wir wollen jetzt mal die Buzzwords auf den Tisch legen.
Also es ist im Endeffekt, was ist das Atom Publishing-Protokoll? Eine Alternative zu XML-RPC oder so? Oder SOAP-basierten Web-Services?
XML-RPC, genau, das wollte ich vorhin eigentlich noch erwähnen. XML-RPC war ja so dieses, ich rufe eine Funktion auf einem anderen Server auf und übertrage die Parameter in XML kodiert hin und her. Das ist ja das, was Dave Weiner gemacht hat, damit man eben auch mit so einem Blogging-Client arbeiten kann. Das und auch dieses Ping hat dieses XML-RPC verwendet. Aber das ist ja eine recht arcane Methode. Das ist so ein bisschen wie C, alles so harte Typen und so weiter. Man kann da nicht wirklich so XML rüber schicken, wie man sich das so denkt, sondern das XML wird nur benutzt, um klassische Standardtypen sowie Integer und Strings zu kodieren. Und Atom bietet da jetzt mehr Flexibilität, bzw. das REST-System bietet mehr Flexibilität. Was hängt denn da jetzt mit was zusammen?
REST ist eine Strategie, wie man Web-Services entwickeln kann. REST ist eine Formulierung eigentlich und Benennung von dem, was eh schon in HTTP, es ist eigentlich eine Rückkehr zu dem nativen Verhalten von HTTP. Also wir haben, wie heißen die HTTP-Verben, get, post, put, delete? Auf Content-Type-Header, auf die diversen HTTP-Header, anstatt dass ich für meine API oder für meine, ja, für meine API in der Web-Applikation zum Beispiel Soap benutze oder XML-RPC, wo ich alles in, im Endeffekt in Envelopes packe, wo ich halt in XML einen Container mache und da rein schreibe ich dann, wie die Methode heißen soll, geht rest, setzt es eine Stufe weiter oben an und sagt, die URL sollten wir doch schon die Methode, beziehungsweise die URL sollten wir die Ressource nennen und dann das HTTP-Verb, die Methode, was ich damit mache.
Jetzt schmeißen wir eine ganze Menge Sachen zusammen. Ich glaube, jetzt müssen wir nochmal ein bisschen Begriffsklärung betreiben. Also wir hatten dieses XML-RPC, das verwendet XML, um diesen Standard, ich ruf dich auf, Methodik zu machen. Du hast Soap erwähnt. Da gab es mal eine ganze Weile lang viele Unterstützer. Microsoft war dabei, andere auch, und alle fanden das ganz toll. Bloß im Vergleich zu einem normalen XML-RPC-Crawl war dieses Soap mit einem unsäglichen Monstrum an XML-Dekoration versehen. Das heißt, man musste auch für ganz einfache Sachen extrem viel Daten durch die Gegend schicken und viele Dinge berücksichtigen. Und dieses REST, wofür steht denn nochmal REST eigentlich genau?
Representational State Transfer. Und ich habe auch kurz mal in diese Distitution reingeschaut, wo das so definiert wurde, aber das war mir dann doch ein bisschen zu hoch.
Aber es ist sozusagen, es nutzt aber, es greift auf eine Ureigenschaft des Web zurück, nämlich dass alles stateless ist. Das heißt, ich mache ein HTTP-Get, so nach dem Motto, gib mir die Webseite, dann gibt die Webseite mir das halt zurück in eine Antwort. Aber das kann alles asynchron voneinander passieren. Das bezieht sich zwar aufeinander, aber es gibt keinen State, es gibt keinen irgendwie jetzt, bis du in diesem Zustand bist, bis du in diesem Zustand bist, bis du in diesem Zustand bist. Bei solchen Remote-Procedure-Calls hat man ja genau diesen State.
Genau, also beim XML, RPC und SOAP und so weiter hat man HTTP überhaupt nicht genutzt. Also man hat immer ein und dieselbe Url abgerufen, ich weiß, XML, RPC, PHP oder irgendwie XML, RPC und dann hat man alles in XML, wie schon gesagt, also Methodennamen und Parameter serialisiert und dann hat man das übergeben und hat wieder zurück in den XML, also in den Reply bekommen. Die Idee beim REST ist einfach, warum benutzen wir nicht HTTP, das schon standardisiert ist, um diese Envelope, also als Envelope, das heißt diese Informationen, welche Methode bzw. auf welche Ressource greife ich zu und welche Methode.
Das ist schon auch ein ganz wichtiger Unterschied, dass es eben nicht mehr um, also du hast nicht diesen einen Endpunkt, wo du halt deine Methoden abrufst, wo du auch dann irgendwie wissen musst, welche Methoden gibt es denn dort überall, dann gibt es dann noch, weiß ich, WSDL, wo ich das dann beschrieben bekomme, welche, ja, die Anteile Overkin?
Ich glaube, das wissen glaube ich viele Leute gar nicht, dass HTTP überhaupt sowas hat wie Methoden. Man denkt immer so, naja, das ist ja das, wo ich der Webseite sage, welche Seite ich jetzt angezeigt kommen möchte, aber jeder Klick ist normalerweise ein Get. Wenn ich auf ein Formular draufklicke, ist es manchmal ein Post, manchmal auch ein Get, dann gibt es noch Put und Delete, genau, was auch manchmal verwendet wird, und Delete. Es gibt da noch ein paar weitere, also über HTTP wird ja zum Beispiel auch modernes Fall-Sharing gemacht, also Web-DFV ist auch eine Erweiterung von HTTP, wo man dann eben diese typischen Fallsystem-Methoden hat, man kann auch Dinge umbenennen und bewegen und so weiter. Also ganz viel basiert mittlerweile auf HTTP, ohne dass man das irgendwie sieht. Und dieses Rest greift im Prinzip jetzt diese Idee auf.
Um einen Satz fertig zu sprechen, statt dass es in Methoden basiert ist, und ich habe eine Methode, was weiß ich, getUsers, und die schicke ich dorthin und dann kriege ich die Antwort, dass es Ressourcen basiert. Das heißt, ich habe eine URL slash users, dort sind alle User. Und jeder User ist wieder durch eine URL repräsentiert. Also zum Beispiel slash users slash Esad. Wenn ich eben die Daten von dort abrufen will, dann mache ich einen getRequest auf diese Ressource. Wenn ich sie ändern will, dann poste ich zum Beispiel was zu dieser Ressource. Wenn ich slashen will, dann schicke ich einen deleteRequest zu dieser Ressource. Also es dreht das um und macht es nicht, also die Methode ist das Wichtige, sondern die Ressource. Und ich habe ein sehr limitiertes Set an Methoden, nämlich getPostDelete, mit denen ich operiere.
Das folgt dieser Crude, also create, retrieve, update, delete, also diese vier wichtigsten Operationen.
Was nicht so ganz eins zu eins macht, getPostDelete, aber worauf geht das jetzt zurück, dieses Crude?
Na Crude ist irgendwie, wie ich das kenne, eine Abkurzung für diese vier wichtigen Operationen, die man über einen Daten machen kann. Und zwar retrieve, update, create, retrieve, update und delete.
Typische Management-Operationen. Jetzt können wir vielleicht den Bogen auch wieder zurückschlagen. Da habe ich vorhin fast den falschen Zeitpunkt aufgemacht. Dieses Atom Publishing-Protokoll bedient sich jetzt, empfiehlt sozusagen diese Restmethodik, also wirklich so in der HTTP-Welt zu leben. Was kann man damit machen?
Etwas, also im Endeffekt einen Atom-Feed, der, wie du erwähnt hast, was ähnliches ist wie RSS, nämlich als eine XML-Repräsentation von meinem Blog zum Beispiel, administrieren. Das mache ich mit Atom Publishing-Protokoll. Da kann ich Atom, Daten, die in Atom repräsentiert sind, also editieren, was hinzufügen, was löschen.
Das ist ganz gut für so ein blogbasiertes System, oder?
Genau, das ermöglicht dann eben Blogging-Clients. Und es ist im Endeffekt eine API, über die andere Services darauf zugreifen können und so weiter.
Das heißt, Atom ist drauf und dran, so das Standardprotokoll zu werden, um klein-seitig Software zu haben, die mit Server-Ressourcen umgeht.
Das kann man sagen.
Also es eignet sich da sehr gut. Das ist sehr wohl durchdacht und ein nettes Paket. Sehr web-nativ.
Back to the web. Genau. Wie ist denn das, ein anderes Ding anzusprechen, mit so Sicherheit? Also Browser ist ja ein wildes Feld. Das haben wir schon gehabt. Und wenn man dann irgendwie 1000 Einfallstore hat und Methoden und Ressourcen und wo man nicht überall was reinposten und hin- und herschicken kann und JavaScript wird durch die Gegend geschickt und Objekte, wie viel Ärger habt ihr denn mit sowas gehabt bei der Entwicklung?
Unser Problem war, dass wir auf Entwicklung fokussiert waren und Features und wir haben Security, also nicht für nachlässig. Genau, und wir haben erst dann was gemacht, wo wir entdeckt haben, jemand hat gesehen, das geht und so weiter. Eine Zeit lang, am Anfang im Prototyp-Phase hatten wir kein Filtering gehabt, so Whitelisting und man könnte ein beliebiges JavaScript inchecken und so weiter. Das haben wir alles mit der Zeit entdeckt und größtenteils diese Sachen, also alles, was wir kennen halt, dass das...
Alles, was es gibt. Vielleicht könnt ihr ja mal ein paar Empfehlungen geben, worauf man da achten soll.
Also eine der ersten Sachen in Web-Securities ist diese SQL-Injection. Das heißt, in meinem Ruby on Rails ist das nicht so wichtig, weil das Framework macht das SQL-Cleanup, was zum Beispiel vielleicht in anderen, ich weiss nicht, in PHP und so weiter, viel wichtiger ist, ist, dass man einfach die Parameter, die reinkommen, also über ein Formular direkt in ein SQL-Query reinschreibt. Und da kann man also Little Bobby Tables, XKCD, also Reference. Man kann zum Beispiel, man macht ein Quot und dann schließt das vorige Query und dann sagt man Drop-Table sowieso und dann ist die Table weg und so weiter.
Also die Empfehlung ist eigentlich generell, dass das, was man von der Server-Seite in den Kleint rein tut und dann wieder zurückbekommt, nicht eins zu eins einfach übernimmt und glaubt, dass das alles der Freund ist, sondern das ist einfach alles der Feind.
Genau, das gilt auch nicht nur für SQL, sondern auch für, weißt du, sich Dateien. Also wenn man, ich weiß nicht, sagen wir, wir haben eine Applikation, die ein Verzeichnis ist, also so ein File, Browser und so weiter, dass man nicht diese Parameter eins zu eins übernimmt und dann lokal diese Files ausliest, weil man kann Request erfälschen oder irgendwas dort schicken, dann kann man auf Systemdateien am Server zugreifen und so weiter. Also alles, was halt User-Input ist und was kommt, sollte man also filtern und ja. Genau.
Gibt's da nicht schon 15 Episoden darüber?
Nicht bei Chaosradio Express. Es gibt natürlich eine ganze Menge Podcasts, die sich jetzt auch dieser Thematik dann nochmal im Detail äußern, aber wir können das durchaus mal ansprechen.
Natürlich. Das zentrale Thema ist, jedem User-Input muss man misstrauen. Also ob da SQL eingeschleust wird oder JavaScript eingeschleust wird mit dem dann böse Sachen gemacht werden, meine Login-Cookies ausgelesen und woanders hingeschickt und so. Das muss man alles filtern und wissen, was man damit tut.
Wie ist denn das so mit den Cookies und dem Session-Management? Weil wir haben ja schon jetzt erwähnt, so Http ist stateless. Das heißt, es gibt auch zwischen dem Request und der Antwort zunächst einmal keinen direkten Bezug. Das heißt, oder sagen wir mal, zwischen dem Request und der Antwort schon, weil das ja über eine Verbindung geht und auch die direkte Antwort ist, aber so zwischen zwei, der zweite Klick muss mit dem ersten erstmal irgendwie zusammengebracht werden. Man weiß ja nicht, woher der kommt. Was für Methoden gibt es denn da und welche sollte man nicht verwenden?
Also jetzt zurück zu Cookies, also Parameter, man kann eine Art Session, also Session Identifier, das heißt, diese eine Session, in der sich ein Benutzer befindet, sollte man irgendwie identifizieren können und auf Daten, die in dieser Session entstehen, auch zurückgreifen können. Eine der Methoden, diese Session Persistence zu machen ist, sind Cookies. Sollten wir eingehen, was Cookies sind, wie sie funktionieren? Also einfach bei einem Reply vom HTTP-Server kann er im Header auch einen Cookie setzen und das speichert der Browser lokal und schickt das mit beim nächsten Request.
Das heißt, der Server kann sozusagen dem Client sagen, hier, merkt ihr das doch mal und wenn ihr mir das das nächste Mal wieder mitschickt, dann weiß ich Bescheid.
Genau, es ist ein Key-Value oder mehrere Key-Value-Pare. Meistens werden im Cookie nicht wirklich die Daten gespeichert, sondern nur eine Session-ID und dann wird Server-Seite geführt, was unter dieser ID noch gespeichert ist.
Das ist auf jeden Fall auch schon mal eine potenzielle Fehlerquelle, wenn man sozusagen da wirklich so Daten drin speichert, die dann, wenn sie wieder reinkommen, einfach so übernommen werden.
Wir wollen den Benutzer, wenn man sich einloggt, dass man eingeloggt bleibt, dass man nicht jedes Mal sich einloggen muss. Das heißt, ich will irgendwie diese Daten speichern, dass diese Session identifiziert ist. Eine der falschen Möglichkeiten wäre, der Username in Cookie zu schreiben. Cookie kann man auch fälschen. Man kann einfach einen Cookiezeugen sagen, mein Username ist so, und dann schickt man das mit und der Server glaubt mir. Hallo, ich bin's, Rot. Deswegen macht man das so, dass man in Cookie nur eine ID, eine random ID, eine Zahl, die man sich nicht ausdenken kann. Genau, und die man auch nicht raten kann. Dann führt man die Daten an der Serverseite. Eine andere Möglichkeit ist, und wird verwendet, wenn Cookies z.B. disabled sind oder könnte verwendet sein, ist, dass man diesen SessionID-Parameter immer in den Url draufhängt.
Das macht man mit den hässlichen URLs.
Genau, das kennt man vielleicht von PHP. PHP ist eine Einstellung in PHP. Wie sollten die SessionIDs geführt werden? Das kennt man so PHP, CSS, IDE oder so.
Was natürlich sehr blöd ist, weil die URL mal leicht was ist, was erstens irgendwo mitgeloggt wird, zweitens, was sich jemand schickt, wenn ich jemand sage, okay, schau auf diese Seite. Und wenn der dann mit meiner SessionID, die in meinem Link drin steht, draufklickt, dann ist er auf einmal eher auch als ich eingeloggt.
Beziehungsweise, da das ja dann wahrscheinlich noch gegen IP-Adressen gegeneinander gecheckt wird, ist es dann aber eine unglückliche URL. Das heißt, eine ungültige URL, sprich, man kann das auch nicht bookmarken, ist eigentlich eine dumme Idee.
Genau, also URLs sind ja ganz zentral, eben auch bei REST noch viel mehr, mit denen sollte man nicht...
Genau, und sie werden meistens auch als Referrer übermittelt. Das heißt, wenn ich einen Link klicke, dann schreibt der Browser auch, er hätte eine Referre-Information, woher kommt dieser Klick? Und wenn man so eine SessionID drinnen hat, dann wird das geloggt auf dem fremden Server. Das sind sozusagen die Basics.
Keine gute Idee.
Genau, und dann gibt es halt... Magst du dieses Cross-Site-Scripting?
Also, welche Session-Management-Methode verwendet ihr? Also, ihr habt Cookies und ihr habt da eine Referenznummer drin.
Genau, wir verwenden...
Wir haben da noch eine Eigenheit, ich weiß nicht, wie sehr man darauf eingehen soll, aber eigentlich eine unserer größten Herausforderungen bei Sub konkret war, dadurch, dass wir ja gesagt haben, das funktioniert auf verschiedenen Domains, du kannst deinen Sub auf deinen eigenen Domain laufen lassen, aber wenn jetzt jemand anderer daherkommt, der auch bei Sub eingeloggt ist, soll deine Seite erkennen können, dass er bei Sub eingeloggt ist, obwohl das bei einem ganz anderen Domain läuft. Und das Hauptsecurity-Modell von JavaScript ist eben das Single-Domain-Origin, also dass nur ein JavaScript, das auf der gleichen Domain läuft, etwas mit Zeiten machen kann, die auf diesem Domain sich befinden. Also ich kann nicht in einem Frame, der auf irgendwas anderes zeigt, dort kann ich nicht zugreifen mit JavaScript und so weiter. Ich kann nicht ein Cookie setzen für einen fremden Domain und solche Sachen. Und das war halt dann kompliziert, einen Mittelweg zu finden, der eben sicher genug ist, wie ich Cross-Domain-Login implementieren kann. Im Endeffekt ist es so, dass wir bei Soup alle sensitiven Cookies nur auf www.soup.io haben und alle User-Subdomains und User-Custom-Domains, auf denen sind nie sensitive Daten. Also wenn dort irgendwas passiert, kann sich nicht jemand einloggen unter deinem Namen. Hat dann ein paar Tricks gebraucht, aber ich glaube, da müssen wir nicht so genau rein.
Das ist ja nur ein Podcast. Hören nur mehrere Tausend Leute zu. Aber ihr fühlt euch jetzt erst mal ausreichend sicher?
Ja, ich meine...
Trickfrage.
Nein, das ist kein Challenge. Ich würde nicht als Challenger sagen, wir sind sicher und zwar sind da Lücken, wenn man sich das genau anschaut. Aber wir haben geschaut, dass diese Basic Cases also gecovert sind und so weiter.
Ja. Macht ihr denn jetzt auch Security-Tests? Oder steht das genauso auf der Liste wie Usability?
Ja, wir haben schon Security-Tests gemacht. Jetzt nicht laufen momentan. Also wir haben keine automatisierten Tests momentan.
Stimmt, aber wir...
Gibt es denn so Websites, die einen so irgendwie beballern on demand?
Das gibt es, haben wir aber noch nicht verwendet, oder?
So Pentest-Maschinen, da komme ich jetzt gerade drauf. Weiß ich gar nicht, ob es sowas gibt.
Ich glaube schon, ja.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Okay, kein Problem. Ja, ja, vielleicht...
Lass uns noch kurz einschneiden. Cross-Site-Request-Fortress ist auch immer ganz böse. Das wird am liebsten übersehen, dass, wenn jemand eingeloggt ist und er kommt auf eine fremde Website, kann ich ihn, ohne dass er das merkt, in seinem Browser dazu bewegen, dass er bestimmte URLs aufruft, die nicht mir gehören. Also, die einfachste Möglichkeit ist, ich mache zum Beispiel einen Image-Tag, ich tue so, als würde ich hier gerade ein Bild laden wollen, aber da schreibe ich dann halt rein, ich weiß nicht, Google-Com, Slash-Search-Quiz, gleich irgendwas, und dann hat er quasi, sein Browser und seine IP hat jetzt diese Google-Suche abgesetzt, ohne dass er es überhaupt weiß. Und eben, wobei Google-Suche vielleicht auch nicht so harmlos ist, da wurden ja auch schon Leute dafür festgenommen. Aber also, wenn ich statt dieser Google-Suche zum Beispiel bei einer Web-Applikation eine URL habe, wenn die aufgerufen wird, dann ändere ich mein Passwort oder so, von dem aktuell eingelogten User, oder dann poste ich was, dann kann ich das mal schnell jemanden unterjubeln, und dann hat er allein durch den Besuch auf meiner bösen Website, hat er diese Aktion woanders getan. Da muss ich nicht mal sein Passwort wissen oder sonst was. Und das wird gerade auch, glaube ich, bei Ruby on Rails Applikationen ganz gern übersehen. Also das hat nicht dagegen, das gibt es bei Ruby on Rails, kein eingebautes...
Was kann man denn dagegen tun?
Genau, was man dagegen tut, ist, man generiert eine Art Token. Wenn eine Aktion, die zum Beispiel wie Change Passwort usw. ausgeführt wird, sie erwartet einen Token. Und dieser Token wird bei der Form, die den Request absetzt, also wo der Request stattfinden soll, wird generiert. Und die Applikation, die das Token generiert hat, weiß, was für einen Token sie erwarten kann. Und der ist meistens von Session abhängig usw.
Im Endeffekt machen wir es sich zu Nütze, dass eben bei dieser Angriffsform jemand einen Befehl quasi absetzen kann, aber nicht auslesen, was dort vorher war und was dort nachher das Ergebnis davon war. Und deswegen schreibe ich einfach vorher quasi einen geheimen Schlüssel dort hinein, der sich jedes Mal ändert, den eben diese Applikation nicht wissen kann. Und das garantiert, dass der User...
Diesen Button darfst du nur wirklich klicken, wenn du mir das sagst, was ich dir vorher zum Geflüstert habe.
In Ruby on Rails gibt es eine, wie soll ich sagen, oft, viel oft übersehene Sicherheitslücke, und zwar, dass in beliebigen Rails-Beispielen, in Rails-Büchern und so weiter wird ein Objekt in der Datenbank erzeugt aus einem Params, also aus HTTP-Parametern, sozusagen per diese Magie. Das heißt, man kann... Man sagt zum Beispiel, man hat eine Form und sagt Sign-up-Formular, und dort sind Login und Passwort. Und meistens ist es so, dass man sagt User.create und dann sagt man Params-User. Und alles, was in diesem Params-User gewesen ist, wird einfach dem Modell übergeben. Wenn man zum Beispiel jetzt denkt und sagt, okay, ich falsche den Request und sage, ich setze auch ein Feld Admin ist gleich True, und in der Datenbank gibt es ein Admin-Feld, dann wird das eins zu eins übernommen ohne jegliches Filtern. Das ist sehr gefährlich.
Das heißt, man hat im Endeffekt ein Formular gebastelt, wo du halt nur zwei Eigenschaften dieses Users definiert hast, nämlich zum Beispiel Username und Passwort. Und die meisten kontrollieren dann nicht, ob wirklich nur diese zwei mitgeschickt wurden oder nicht zusätzliche. Und wenn da zufällig jemand weiß, wie meine zusätzlichen Felder heißen, kann er diese Werte eben auch setzen.
Sind wir im Prinzip aber wieder da, wo wir vorhin schon waren. Man darf einfach nicht einfach eins zu eins das übernehmen so ungeprüft sein. Man muss eigentlich immer eine Translation drin haben.
Das ist halt schon konkret ein Framework-Problem hier.
Weil das so einfach gemacht wird, dass man mit einer Zeile einfach alle Parameter übernehmen kann. Genau, genau. Das soll man halt nicht machen. Das größte Problem ist, dass das heute auch, wenn man die neueste Ausgabe von dem Rails-Buch, steht das irgendwo klein in einem Tipp. Das ist nicht irgendwie...
Das Kleingedruckte sozusagen.
Und das soll man beachten.
Ja, das war jetzt schon ein ziemlich umfangreicher Durchmarsch durch die Web-Technologien, aber da soll es mir auch darum gehen. Ich denke, das haben wir jetzt auch ganz gut zusammengefasst. Weiter vertiefen müssen wir es jetzt nicht. Zum Abschluss würde ich ganz gerne noch mal auf eure kulturellen Erfahrungen zu sprechen kommen, die ihr mit eurer Soup-Gemeinde gemacht habt. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das ein ganz lustiger Haufen ist. Ich bin mal so durch die eine oder andere Suppe, habe ich mich mal durchgeschlürft. Und das ist ja schon absurde Spaßmengen, die da so auf einen zugerollt kommen. Was ist das für ein Gefühl, wenn man da so die zentrale Instanz ist?
Macht das Spaß?
Na ja, es ist vor allem etwas schwer zu entwickeln, weil man beim Testen zum Beispiel immer abgelenkt wird. Man scrollt ein bisschen und sieht, ah, ein Video, ich schaue mir das Video.
Genau, du willst nur ein Feature testen, und das musst du halt auf der Startseite machen, wo du halt bei uns alles siehst, was alle Leute gepostet haben, in einer großen, unendlich lang scrollenden Suppe. Und da bleibt man dann oft mal zwei Stunden hängen und dann warte, irgendwas wollte ich da eigentlich machen. Ich bin doch aus irgendeinem Grund hier.
Ach, das ist ja übrigens noch so ein knuffiges Feature, was ihr eingebaut habt mit diesem unendlichen Scrolling. Kannst du das mal erläutern?
Das gibt es zum Beispiel, kennen die Leute vielleicht von Google Reader, dem RSS-Reader von Google, dass wenn ich am Ende der Seite bin und trotzdem weiter nach unten scrolle, dann lädt einfach Inhalt nach, auch über Ajax eben. Das heißt, ich kann da ewig nach unten scrollen und es hört nie auf.
Bis der Browser irgendwann platzt.
Bis der Browser abstürzt oder du zum Anfang unserer Datenbank kommst.
Füllt ihr da nur hinzu oder nehmt ihr da auch wieder was raus?
Wir nehmen jetzt in der neuen Version genau.
Wir nehmen oben was raus, weil sonst kommt es echt ziemlich bald zu diesem Browserabstürz.
Ein Nachteil ist, wenn man dann wieder zurückkommt, also oben ist der Inhalt weg. Aber wir haben auch eine Version überlegt, wo dann Inhalt auch nach oben nachgeladen wird, wenn man dann zurück scrollt und so weiter.
Der Punkt ist, das passt halt ganz gut zu diesen neuen Metaphern und zu dieser Art von Inhalt, die da ist, weil eben auch das Wort Tumblelog, wo Sachen so vorbeipurzeln. Die einzelnen Posts sind nicht so prominent, dass ich da jetzt noch mal draufklick und mir das lang durchlese oder so. Sondern ich kann da schnell mal vorbeiscrollen, manche Sachen interessieren mich, manche nicht. Ich habe zum Beispiel auch nicht diesen Druck, dass ich alles gesehen haben muss. Also wie, wenn ich in meinem RSS-Reader stehe, dann halt, ich weiß nicht, von irgendeinem Blog, habe ich 15 Posts ungelesen und das ist so ein Druck. Oh mein Gott, ich muss diese 15 Posts lesen. Wenn ich dann mal auf Urlaub fahre und zurückkomme, dann steht da 1700 und dann denke ich mir, das war auch ganz wichtig, dass wir auch diese psychologischen Hürden wegnehmen. Also einerseits, oh ich muss jetzt da was Wichtiges reinschreiben, ich muss jetzt einen tollen Gedankengang haben, der noch nie auf der Welt existiert hat. Wir wollen es den Leuten so einfach wie möglich machen, was zu publizieren und da nicht Qualitätsansprüche anlegen. Was, also manchmal die Kritik ist so, also Webblogs sind doch eh schon, da gibt es diese Duden-Definition. Katzenbilder, genau.
Genau, Internet-Tagebuch mit Katzenbildern.
Fukami hat mal so ganz nett beschrieben als so, warum soll ich einen Blog führen, wenn ich doch auch einfach nur Katzenbilder klicken kann. Das macht doch mehr Spaß. Aber wir lassen uns da eigentlich gar nicht drauf ein auf diese Wertigkeitsdiskussion, was jetzt, also das Internet ist groß genug, Speicherplatz ist billig, jeder kann da reinhauen, was er will. Das muss nicht jemanden moralisch absolut entscheiden, was jetzt wert ist, gepostet zu werden und was nicht. Und es ist ja, as I said, eben eine sehr persönliche Art des Publizierens, weil das hauptsächlich meine Freunde interessieren wird, was ich mir da zusammen sammle. Und vielleicht nicht jetzt jemanden, den ich überhaupt nicht kenne. Aber genau, und so passt halt zusammen, dass ich da einfach schnell durchscrollen kann und mir Sachen rauspicken, die ich dann reposte oder ja, einfach.
Spaß am Netz. Ich denke, da haben wir es doch zusammen. Christopher und Esad, vielen Dank für das ausführliche Gespräch. Die Suppenfabrikanten des Internets. Und ja, vielleicht habt ihr auch Spaß mit Soups. soup.io, könnt ihr ja mal klicken. Ist auf jeden Fall sehr lustig. Viele Katzenbilder und auch andere tolle Sachen sind dort zu finden. Ja, und ich sage danke. Das war es, Chaosradio Express 72, Web-Technologien einmal durchgestiefelt. Vielen Dank und tschüss. Und auch an euch, Hörer. Tschüss und danke fürs Zuhören. Wie immer mit der Bitte um Feedback auch zu dieser Sendung. Entweder im Blog unter blog.chaosradio.ccc.de oder wenn euch das mehr liegt, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de. E-Mails schicken und mal gucken. Vielleicht machen wir ja auch nochmal eine Chaosradio-Suppe auf. Da können wir nochmal ein bisschen verrücktes Zeug rein gucken. Mal schauen, was dabei rauskommt. Tschüss!